there are many hazards associated with
operating combines and additional
dangers can be present
under time constraints farmers recognize
that the success of their business
depends on harvesting their crops making
it too easy to ignore
safety precautions it is essential to
observe safety instructions clearly
outlined in the combine operator's
manual
operate combines only when all guards
are correctly installed
when parking and leaving a combine lower
the header unit to the ground
remove the keys apply the brakes
and lock the cab
read the safety section of the combine
operator's manual
to become familiar with location and
meaning of all safety decals
and to help locate all safety shields
and guards on the combine you are
operating
be sure hazard lights are on and
flashing while driving a combine on
roads
and use turn signal lights to signal
turns
to avoid motorist confusion do not
operate combine rear discharge lights
on public roads
the combine operator is essential to
safe combine operation
operators must be thoroughly familiar
with the operating controls and safety
features
combines are large machines and if not
operated correctly
can easily cause damage to other
equipment and injury to people
never operate a combine if you have not
been trained on all
aspects of combine operation combine
operators must be comfortable and with
an
easy reach of combine controls to drive
safely
before operating the combine adjust the
seat and steering column
so you can reach all controls easily
the wheels that steer self-propelled
combines are rear mounted
steering requires practice since rear
steering causes the rear end of the
combine to swing around rapidly
operators must stay alert to avoid
hitting equipment
and individuals
combines have a large operator cab large
enough for a rider in addition to the
operator
however even though the rider may be
safe inside the combine cab
the extra person can easily be a
distraction to the operator
the extra seat is intended for use to
instruct
new operators and only for short time
periods
use the combine horns to signal moving
away
since combines are such large machines
it can be difficult for the operator to
see
people on the ground individuals who are
required to work in areas where combines
are moving
need to be instructed in combine safety
practices
as well as the operators avoid making
sharp turns
be particularly careful when turning on
slopes and uneven ground
operating steering and braking of
combines can be affected by the heavy
weight of headers
it may be necessary to add ballast
weights to the rear of combines
to compensate for the header weight
always lower the header attachment to
the ground
before performing maintenance on it if
the work requires that the header be
lifted
provide secure support under the header
shut off the combine engine set the
parking brake
and remove the ignition key before
performing maintenance or adjustments on
any part of the machine
unloading the grain tank on a combine
involves coordination between the
combine operator
and the truck or grain cart operator
never enter the grain tank
while the combine's engine is running
always have another person present when
doing maintenance on combine grain tanks
know the location of fire extinguishers
on a combine before operating it
be sure the fire extinguishers are
properly serviced and charged
stop harvesting immediately at the first
sign of fire
regularly remove any buildups of straw
or chaff
in or near the engine compartment or
moving parts
following safety precautions does take a
little more time
but being safe is your number one
commodity
you